PROFESSOR: So what do we do?
We are going to sum
over final states
the probability to go
from i to final at time t0
to first order.
Since the sum of our final
states is really a continuum,
this is represented
by the integral
of the f i t0 1, multiplied
by the number of states
at every little interval.
So this will go rho of Ef dEf.
So this is what we developed
about the number of states.
So I'm replacing this--
I have to sum but
I basically decide
to call this little dN,
the little number of states
in here, and then I'm going to
integrate this probability, so
the number of states over
there, and therefore the dN
is replaced by rho times dEf.
So then this whole transition
probability will be 4 integral,
I'm writing now the integral,
VfI squared, sine squared,
omega f i t0 over 2 Ef minus
Ei squared, rho of Ef, d of Ef.
And you would say
at this moment,
OK, this is as far
as you go, so that
must be Fermi's golden
rule, because we
don't know rho of Ef, it's
different in different cases,
so we have to do that integral
and we'll get our answer.
But the great thing
about this golden rule
is that you can go far and
you can do the integral.
Now I don't even know, this
VfI also depends on the energy,
how am I ever going
to do the integral?
That seems outrageous.
Well, let's try to do
it, and part of the idea
will be that we're going
to be led to the concept
that we already
emphasized here because
of this suppression, that
only a narrow band of states
contribute, and in
that narrow band,
if the narrow band is narrow
enough, in that region
VfI high be
approximately constant
in a narrow enough
region, and rho
will be approximately constant.
So we'll take them
out of the integral,
do the rest of the
integral, and see later
whether the way we're
doing the integral
shows that this
idea is justified.
So I'll just-- you
know, sometimes you
have to do these things,
of making the next step,
so I'll do that.
I'll take these things
out, assuming they're
constant enough, and then we'll
get 4 VfI squared, rho of E,
what should I put here?
E sub i, is that right?
Because if it's all evaluated
at the initial energy Ei,
if only a narrow
band will contribute,
I'll put an h squared here so
that this will become omega fi,
and now I will integrate over
the sum range of energies
the function sine squared
omega f t0 over 2,
over omega fi squared dEf.
So I just took the thing
out of the integral
and we're going to hope
for some luck here.
Whenever you have an integral
like that it probably
is a good idea to plot
what you're integrating
and think about it and
see if you're going
to get whatever you wanted.
Look, I don't know how far
I'm going to integrate,
I probably don't
want to integrate
too far because then these
functions that I took out
of the integral
are not constants,
so let's see what
this looks like,
the integrand,
this function here.
Well, sine squared
of x over x squared
goes to 1, you know when--
this we're plotting as
a function of omega fi.
Why?
Time is not really what we're
plotting into this thing,
we're plotting-- we're
integrating our energy,
Ef, omega fi is Ef minus Ei,
so omega is the variable you
should be plotting, and
when omega goes to zero,
this whole interval goes
like t0 squared over 4,
and then sine squared of x
over x squared does this thing,
and the first step here is
2 pi over t0, 2 pi over t0
and so on.
And now you smile.
Why?
Because it's looking
good, this thing.
First what's going
to be this area?
Well, if I look at
this lobe, roughly, I
would say height t0 squared with
1 over t0, answer proportional
to t0.
This whole integral is going
to be proportional to t0.
The magic of the combination
of the x squared growth,
t0 squared and
the oscillation is
making into this
integral being linear
in t0, which is the probability
the transition [INAUDIBLE]
is going to grow
linearly is going
to be a rate, as we expected.
So this is looking very good.
Then we can attempt to see that
also most of the contribution
here happens within this
range to the integral.
If you look at the integral of
sine squared x over x squared,
90% of the integral
comes from here.
By the time you have these
ones you're up to 95%
of the integral.
Most of the integral
comes within those lobes.
And look what I'm going
to say, I'm going to say,
look, I'm going to try
to wait long enough,
t0 is going to be long enough so
that this narrow thing is going
to be narrower and narrower and
therefore most of the integral
is going to come from
omega fi equal to 0,
which means the f equals to Ei.
If I wait long enough with
t0, this is very narrow,
and even all the other
extra bumps are already
4 pi over t0 over
here is just going
to do it without any problem,
it's going to fit in.
So another way of
thinking of this
is to say, look, you could
have argued that this is going
to be linear in t0 if you just
change variables here, absorb
the t0 into the energy,
change variable,
and the t0 will go out of
the integral in some way,
but that is only true if the
limits go from minus infinity
to plus infinity.
So I cannot really integrate
from minus infinity to plus
infinity in the final
energies, but I don't need
to because most of the integral
comes from this big lobe here,
and if t0 is sufficiently large,
it is really within no energy
with respect to the energy, Ei.
So our next step is
to simply declare
that a good approximation
to this integral
is to integrate the whole
thing from minus infinity
to infinity, so let me say this.
Suppose here in this range omega
fi is in between 2 pi over t0
and minus 2 pi over t0.
What does this tell us that
omega fi is in this region?
Well, this is Ef minus Ei over
h bar so this actually tells you
Ef is in between Ei
plus 2 pi h bar over t0,
and Ei minus 2 pi h bar over t0.
All right, so this
is the energy range
and as t0 becomes larger and
larger, the window for Ef
is smaller and smaller, and
we have energy conserving.
So let's look at our integral
again, the integral is I,
that's for the integral,
this whole thing,
will be equal to
integral dEf sine squared
of omega fi t0 over 2
over omega fi squared.
So what do we do?
We call this a variable, u,
equal omega fi t0 over 2,
so that du is dEf
t0 over 2 h bar,
because omega fi is
Ef minus Ei, and Ef is
your variable of integration.
So you must substitute
the dEf here
and the rest of the integron.
So what do we get from the
dEf and the other part?
You get at the end h bar
t0 over 2 integral from--
well, let's leave it, sine
squared u over u squared du.
So look at this, the
omega fi squared,
by the time you get here omega
fi goes like 1 over time,
so when it's down here we'll
give you a time squared,
but the dE gives you 1 over
time so at the end of the day
we get the desired linear
dependence on t0 here,
only if the integral
doesn't have t0 in here,
and it will not have it if you
extend it from minus infinity
to infinity.
And there's no error,
really, in extending it
from minus infinity to
infinity because you basically
know that n lobes
are going to fit here
and are going to be accurate,
because there is little energy
change if t0 is large enough.
If t0 is large enough, even a
20 pi h bar and a 20 by h bar
here, that still will do it.
So we integrate like
that, we extend it,
and we get this whole
integral has value pi,
so we get h bar t0 pi over
2, that's our integral, I.
So our transition
probability, what is it?
We have it there,
over there, we'll
have the sum over final states,
i to f of t0, first order
is equal to the integral
times this quantity,
so that quantity
is h t0 pi over 2,
so it's 4, what do
we have, VfI squared,
rho of Ei over h squared,
then h bar t0 pi over 2.
So your final answer
for this thing
is 2 pi over h bar VfI
squared, rho of Ei t0.
So let's box, this is
a very nice result,
it's almost Fermi's
golden rule by now.
Let's put a time t
here, t0 is a label,
not to confuse our time
integrals or things like that,
so we could put
the time, t, here,
is 2 pi over h bar VfI
squared rho of Ei t.
From here we have
a transition rate,
so a transition rate is
probability of transition
per unit time, so
a transition rate
would be defined as the
probability of transition
after a time t, divided by
the time t that has elapsed,
and happily, this has worked
out so that our transition rate,
w is 2 pi over h bar
VfI squared rho of Ei,
and this is Fermi's
golden rule, a formula
for the transition rate to
the continuum of final states.
You see, when I see
[INAUDIBLE] it almost
seemed you still
have to integrate,
there is a rho of E and
let's integrate [INAUDIBLE]
but the interval has been
done and it says transmission
amplitude squared evaluated
at the state initial
and final with the same
energy and final state,
and the rho evaluated at the
energy of the initial state.
You don't have to
do more with that.
So we have this formula, let's
look at a couple more things.
Do units work out?
Yes, this is transition per
unit, this is 1 over time,
this is energy squared,
this is 1 over energy,
and this is an h bar, this
will give you 1 over time,
so this thing goes well.
How about our assumptions?
This was calculated using some
time t, we used to call it t0.
How large does it have to be?
Well, the larger it is the
more accurate the integral is,
but you don't want
to take it too large,
either, because
the larger it is,
the transition
probability eventually
goes wrong at first order
of perturbation theory.
So this argument is valid
if there is a time, t0,
that is large enough so that
within this error bars, rho
and the transition matrix
elements are constant so
that your integral is valid.
But this t0 being large
enough should be small enough
that the transition probability
doesn't become anywhere near 1.
That will happen in general or
if VfI is sufficiently small,
so when VfI is sufficiently
small, this will always hold,
and in physical applications
this happens and it's OK.
So that's our presentation
and derivation
of Fermi's golden rule,
and we will turn now
to one application
and we will discuss.